we all have milestones in life that we
remember so vividly
the first one for me was when i was
entering kindergarten
my big brother was in school and by
golly it was my time
and i went trotting down that hallway i
was so excited i almost wet myself
and i go to the door and there was a
teacher with a warm welcome
and she took me into the classroom
showed me my little cubby hole we all
remember those little cubby holes don't
we
and we put our stuff in there and then
she said go over to the circle and play
with the kids
until class starts so i went over there
and plopped down like i owned the place
and i'm playing and all of a sudden the
boy next to me he was wearing
a white shirt with blue shorts i
remember it like it was yesterday
and suddenly he stopped playing and he
said why are you so
short and i just kept playing i didn't
think he was talking to me
and in a louder voice he said hey why
are you so short
so i looked up and i said what what are
you talking about let's just play
we're happy i've been waiting for this
and so we played and about a minute
later the girl next to him
and a white shirt and a pink skirt stood
up put her hands on her hips and said
yeah why do you look so different and i
went
what are you talking about i don't look
different i'm not sure
again let's just play about this time i
looked all around the circle i was in
and all the kids had stopped playing and
they were all looking at me
and i'm thinking in today's language it
would be omg
or wtf
what just happened so all the confidence
that i went in with that morning was
was withering away as the morning went
on and the questions kept coming
and at the end of the morning before we
went home the teacher had us in a circle
and i actually found myself outside of
the circle i couldn't look at anybody
i could not understand what just
happened
and over the next few years i hated to
go out in public
i felt every stare every giggle every
pointed finger
not the finger but every pointed finger
and i hated it i would hide behind my
parents legs like nobody could see me
and as a child you can't understand
another child's curiosity
nor an adult's ignorance and it became
became very apparent to me that the real
world was not built
for someone of my size both literally or
figuratively
and so i have no anonymity as you can
probably tell
and while you can see my size we all go
through many challenges
through our lifetime and some you can
see
like mine most you can't you can't tell
if someone's dealing with a mental
illness
or they're struggling with their gender
identity they're caring for an aging
parent
they're having financial difficulty you
can't see that kind of stuff
so while you can see one of my
challenges as my size
seeing does not mean you understand what
it's truly to be me
on a daily basis or what i go through
and so i'm here to debunk a myth
i do not believe you can walk in someone
else's shoes
and because of that we must adopt a new
way of giving of ourselves
simply stated i will never know what
it's like to be you
and you will never know what it's like
to be me i cannot face your fears or
chase your dreams and you can't do
that for me but we can be supportive of
each other
instead of trying to walk in each
other's shoes we must adopt a new way of
giving of
ourselves i learned at an early age
that i did have to do some things
different than most people
but i also learned there were things i
was on equal footing with
and one of those was the classroom
i was equal as a matter of fact i
excelled in the classroom
this was vitally important i discovered
as i grew older
and realized i wasn't going to be able
to do a physical job
i needed an education so i went on and
got a university degree
but i felt to be one step ahead of
everyone for employment
i needed to have an advanced university
degree
so i went ahead and got that now i'm
ready for my interview
remember your first interview what am i
going to wear
what questions and don't forget that
firm handshake
i was right there with you until 24
hours before my interview a friend of
mine who i've known all my life
called and said michelle the building
you're going in has steps
and she knew i couldn't climb steps so
suddenly my focus changed in my shoes
i was worried about how am i going to
get there
so i went early and i found a loading
dock and got in and had a great
interview
they had no idea what i went through for
the day and that's okay
you're probably thinking my greatest
challenge that day was the interview
or getting in the building in reality my
biggest challenge that day
was getting through the loading dock
without getting run over
i am very vulnerable in certain
situations
airports hallways parking lots
loading decks and so i have to be very
careful i have to anticipate
and be flexible and move as quickly as i
can sometimes
so i got the job and in my current role
i travel quite a bit
and travel is a challenge for all of us
these days
and so you probably get to the airport
run through security get to the gate
did i get my aisle seat on my window
seat did i get my upgrade
me first of all i don't run through
anything
and i especially don't run through the
tsa because i get to experience the
personal pat down
i won't comment on that and then i make
my way to the gate
and with my gift of gab that my parents
said i was born with
i talked to the gate agent and i say by
the way my scooter weighs this much
i have a dry cell battery and i can
drive it down to the door of the plane
also the day before i had called the
city where i'm traveling to
to find out where i could rent a scooter
in case mine gets broken
on the way so in my shoes it's a little
bit different
when i get onto the plane i use my gift
of gab to ask somebody to put my bag up
and they graciously do i try not to eat
or drink on a planks i don't want to
have to get up and walk
on a plane but nature has its own
schedule and not long ago
it knocked and i answered so i walk up
to the front of the plane
and gab with the flight attendant and
say can you watch the door
i can't reach the lock so i'm
in there doing my business and the door
flies open
and there's a gentleman there with the
look of horror on his face
just i'm sure i had the same look as
they came out
i noticed that he was sitting right
across from me
and he's in total complete embarrassment
so i walk up to him and i quietly go are
you going to remember this as much as i
am
and he goes i think so
now while he's probably not talking
about it publicly i am
[Music]
but we talked for the rest of the flight
and we got to know each other our
families sports work
and when we landed he said michelle i
noticed someone put your bag up can i
get that for you i said of course thank
you
and we wished each other well and the
most important thing that day was that
he was not going to leave with that
embarrassment
you know that experience of
embarrassment he won't forget it neither
will i
but i think he will remember more our
chat
and our different perspectives when you
travel internationally
it can be even more challenging in
certain ways a few years ago i was in
zanzibar
and i come wheeling in and think about
that
short white blonde
woman in a chair that doesn't probably
happen every day
so i go up and with my gift of gab i
start to talk to the agent
so so friendly and they ask about their
culture and so forth and
i noticed there wasn't a jet bridge so i
had to kind of say
not only do you have to lift my chair i
could use some help getting up the steps
and we got to spend about an hour
together while we waited for the flight
and it was the most magnificent hour our
perspective changed for both of us that
day
and once i got on the flight he patted
me on the back and wished me well
and i i thanked him so much and again
i think he's going to remember that
experience
more than when i first came in and there
was a bit of hesitation
and as you notice i get a lot of help i
would not be where i
am today if it was not for my family my
friends
my colleagues and the many strangers
that helped me
every single day of my life
and it's important that we all have a
support system asking for help
is a strength not a weakness
we all need help throughout our lifetime
but
it is just as important that we are part
of
other people's support system we must
adopt that way of giving back
we all obviously have a role to play in
our own successes
but think about the role we have to play
in other people's successes just like
people do for me
every single day
it's vitally important that we help each
other
because society is increasingly
placing people in silos
based on biases and ideologies
and we must look past the surface
and be confronted with the truth that
none of us
are what you can see there's more to us
than that
and we're all dealing with things that
you cannot see
so living a life free of judgment allows
all of us to share those experiences
together
and have a totally different perspective
just like the couple people i mentioned
earlier in my stories
so remember the only shoes you truly can
walk in
are your own i cannot walk in yours
i know you can't walk in my sized ones
but you can try but we can do something
better than that
with compassion courage and
understanding
we can walk side by side and support one
another
and think about how society can change
if we all do that
instead of judging on only what you can
see
thank you
[Applause]
thank you